ah allez vous avez vu pour renforcer son
mariage
une américaine à vous donner le saint à
son mari est-ce que vous avez vu ça il
est incroyable tous les coups pour leur
petites habitudes bah regardez
je ne vois pas ce qu'il y a de mal à
allaiter mon mari
on m'a dit qu'il pouvait boire d'autres
lait parce que boire le lait d'une
personne qu'on connaît les gens trouvent
ça bizarre
mais je voulais en parler pour que les
autres qui le font ne se sentent pas
seuls
c'est juste naturel en fait c'est du
liquide du lait naturel qui vient d'un
être humain
ça me fait de mal à personne ni à moi ni
à elle c'est juste nécessaire
le travail j'ai mal j'aime pas les
tire-lait
bon
cette histoire par jour
même dans le bus parfois il se met sur
des genoux en tout cas apparemment
on ressent des hommes qui auraient déjà
goûté le lait maternel de de Madame donc
il y a quand même des gens qui essayent
après personnellement moi j'aurais pas
envie de téter un sein personnellement
mais c'est
quoi
peut-être à la limite c'est plus
négociable
il a une plus belle peau après
effectivement
elle a raison parce qu'elle vient
d'avoir un troisième enfant donc c'est
pour ça qu'elle a qu'elle a encore du
lait dans les gélules
et donc elle prend la précaution de dire
enfin j'arrête d'abord mon troisième
enfant et après mon mari c'est quand
même très fort
une séance chez le petit s'impose
et qu'après s'il y a un reste et ben
c'est son mari donc à la rigueur c'est
la pression
en période de crise ça coûte moins cher
le matin et puis comme Flex et tout
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous savez d'ailleurs
pourquoi les hommes ont des seins alors
qu'ils n'allaient pas est-ce que vous
savez pourquoi
l'invité exceptionnel de TPMP
ne se développe qu'à partir de 6
semaines dans chez le foetus et du coup
le corps n'attend pas pour se développer
sur les complexes
parce que j'ai deux je sais pas j'ai
deux yeux j'ai deux narines maintenant
parce que la probabilité qu'on est deux
qu'une femme est deux petits enfin il y
a des jumeaux et c'est la plus la
probabilité la plus grosse virgule 6%.
alors que par exemple d'avoir des
triplés c'est 0,03 autrement
les chiens les chiens parce qu'ils ont
beaucoup des des portées beaucoup plus
grosses
intéressant c'est clair comme de l'eau
dedans pourquoi les seins deviennent
foncer
les tétons sont foncés parce que le bébé
ignote il ne voit rien donc il devient
plus foncé pour qu'il le trouve plus
facilement
tu as d'autres choses
je peux trouver
qu'est-ce qui est hyper intéressant
j'espère
Kim Jong-un qui en visite en Russie il
s'est déplacé à bord d'un train aussi
luxueux que blindé et ultra sécurisé le
dirigeant coréen veut rencontrer
Vladimir Poutine pour trouver un accord
sur l'armement notamment avec ce qui se
passe en Ukraine regardez ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur de ce train c'est fou
bunker ambulant une forteresse sur rail
il y a 90 wagons qui sont complètement
blindés il y a des fusil d'assaut à
l'intérieur on dit même qu'il y a un
hélicoptère dedans auquel il faudrait
l'évacuer d'urgence c'est complètement
dingue le train est tellement lourd qui
lui est impossible de prendre de la
vitesse et donc qu'il roule à 60 km/h il
y a aussi donc des filles qui sont
invités à bord de ce train avant le
voyage elle passe un examen médical pour
voir si elles sont vierges on sait pas
si elles sont biens à la fin du voyage
ou pas et aussi des contrôleurs de train
femmes donc en uniforme de contre
l'ordre de train toujours très belle qui
chante des chansons pendant le voyage
c'est incroyable ça c'est quoi cette
histoire non mais c'est c'est une
dynastie et Kim qui est totalement
paranoïaque depuis
60 70 ans depuis la séparation des deux
Corées et comme ils savent que les
Américains se renseignent beaucoup par
satellite sur leur déplacement
ils utilisent d'abord des sosies ensuite
ils répliquent 90 fois les wagons qui
sont aussi identiques vu de l'extérieur
ils ont une ligne qui est réservée qui
s'appelle la ligne Kim qui leur permet
d'accéder à leurs différents domicile
et ils ont tous ce qu'il faut pour vivre
à l'intérieur ce train pendant plusieurs
jours qui sont sélectionnés pour lui
parce que c'est une dictature donc elles
ont pas le choix il est fait venir et
après on sait pas ce qui se passe dans
le train mais il est complètement barjot
il a fait assassiner
son demi-frère quand même
[Rires]
il y a un
j'adore incroyable les chéris vous avez
vu Joe Biden lors d'une conférence de
presse donnait l'occasion d'une visite
diplomatique au Vietnam Mushkin Joe
Biden
je te jure il enchaîner des réponses
toutes plus confuses des unes que les
autres avant de clôturer la conférence
de presse de façon très surprenante il
était mochekine
regardez Joe Biden michkina
[Musique]
il répondait à une question sur le
dérèglement climatique et il arrive à
parler de films de John Wayne etc donc
là et ça a été interrompu à la
conférence a été interrompue par mais il
va se représenter Joey cas c'est ce que
les démocrates ont l'intention de faire
qui se représente mais il commence à y
avoir une polémique sur est-ce que c'est
bien sage de reconduire je n'ose
imaginer ce que serait si c'était Donald
Trump dans cet état ce que dirait les
démocrates c'est à dire la gauche
américaine de l'eau c'est devenu
là il y a quand même un grand problème
de discernement on parle de quelqu'un on
a un pays enfin on a un monde qui est
quand même en guerre il y a la puissance
voilà il y a la puissance atomique
c'est quelqu'un qui a des briefs de
sécurité de renseignements de très haut
niveau tous les matins à 7h30 à la
maison la Maison Blanche bon ça fait ça
la Maison Blanche c'est la Maison
Blanche c'est comme un orchestre
c'est-à-dire que ça peut fonctionner
sans lui et puis en plus il y a un
vice-président il y a des généraux
d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'à
l'époque quand il y avait beaucoup de
gens qui critiquaient Donald Trump on
avait l'habitude de dire mais c'est pas
vraiment lui faire je veux dire il peut
la maison elle fonctionne sans lui mais
il y a eu tellement de bourdes que
d'ailleurs maintenant aux États-Unis on
appelle ça les bidens moments
c'est-à-dire que
et donc en fait ils sont tellement
habitués que voilà c'est c'est parti du
bah du coup c'est un boulevard pour
Trump puisqu'il est plus il est condamné
plus il est numéro un des sondages
ils ont le même âge
il a 3 ans de plus
à trouver quelqu'un de plus ils arrivent
ils arrivent pas à trouver quelqu'un qui
puisse
elle sait pas finalement imposée
spécialement brillé donc il y a pas
évident quand tu as plusieurs métiers
c'est relou pourquoi c'est quoi son
autre métier elle est pas dans le pain
de Miss alors
tu peux pas tout faire un moment tu as
des priorités frère on va partir en